anderson tries to get him started the
right way at home tonight yeah looking
for a bounce back he got beat by the
pirates his last timeout that was game
one of the double header 2019 that's a
good start for anderson a change-up
strikes out robles and
it's okay to begin the night for the
left-hander
and he rips that one out to right center
avisae garcia over to cut it off holding
juan do a base hit and he's now been on
base this is amazing 28 of his last 42
played appearances
there's a little roller to third base
escobar will wind it up and anderson a
scoreless first inning patrick corbin 32
years old 6-3 2-10 about six runs on
seven hits last time out against the
braves on august 14th over four and two
thirds
that's a beauty
strikeout number 101 for corbin in 127
innings
fastball away and corbin
maybe making guys mindful of that slider
got it by it
lane thomas with a runner at first got a
chance to turn it adamus
and the throw to first is in time
nicely done orios
was waiting at the bag he's got a strong
arm
and a 6-4-3 double play wipes out a
lead-off walk rowdy teles one of the new
brewers
corbin's got the slider working adams
has to scramble to go get it
so three strikeouts in two innings two
grounders a routine fly ball patrick's
knight off to a very good start in
wisconsin
so patrick corbin now and a cold strike
three corbin is out
kane four for 23 on the last road trip
back in there against patrick corbin the
left-hander throws a swinging line drive
down the left field line of fair ball
could be extra bases for kane hits off
the side wall here's going to be a play
at second base not going to be in time
kane is in with a standing double to
lead off here in the third
one ball one strike kane takes off no
throw
so kane gets there anyway
pina couldn't advance him kane with a
stolen base
and now a lot of ways to score a run
but corbin will get the strikeout
on a ball that just nicked the outside
edge escobar laced one to tyrone taylor
and left first time up
off to the races barehand play
pretty well made but escobar the other
escobar eduardo had no chance
and the nats have their lead off man on
for the second time
here's soto here's a 1-2 sono takes a
call strike three so anderson fools him
strikes him out third k for brett
anderson short lead for escobar at first
to one pitch ground ball right side base
hit escobar is going to stop at second
base smartly garcia got to that ball
quickly it's going to be first and
second we'll see if lane thomas can
deliver with two outs to put the nats on
top there he goes and that's down the
line
this guy can run
it should score two
thomas
will drive in a couple heading for third
and then actually two nothing
he hit it where they weren't
that's what i'm talking about and just
like that it's two nothing
on the foul tip of fastball up and away
number five for patrick corbin adamus
twice
a swing says chris siegel done it first
two k's in the inning
patrick corbin retiring six in a row
before the cane double and now six in a
row after the kane doubles
oh that was in on his hands and he hit
it into the right field corner
so garcia turns on one both deadens in
the corner and for a moment we thought
he might keep going
lead off double for the net's number
eight hitter
oh two pitch ureas back up the middle
and a base hit just out of the reach of
garcia
this guy can swing the bat ureas
just brings those hands in tight slaps
it back up the middle and the brewers
have a lead man on
got him on the slider down and in
number seven for patrick corbin
five shutout innings on only two hits
under his belt
so a base hit a hard line out a steal
fifth inning not a problem for our lefty
it's going to be hunter strickland now
he has stranded six of seven inherited
runners this year as a brewer rock
across his 40 games he's got two
inherited runners out there right now
and the 1-2 pitch is in there a cold
strike three
fooled him with a fastball
and hunter strickland with a big
strikeout for out number two
ball up base hit left field
soto around
throw coming home
and he's safe mark carlson calls him
safe pina points to the dugout for a
possible challenge
and cut down the distance between third
base and home plate just to beat the
throw and to give his ball club a three
to nothing lead
challenge fastball tapper bell corbin
well done two down
why not here's escobar
great inning for patrick corbin after
his teammates
got him a lead a little frustration for
the first place brewers tonight
norris deals a swing and a miss he got
him pina's got to secure it at first he
does
norris strikes him out
oh that ball's hit
not coming back
garcia
goodbye
in a flash out of here
number 24 for avi garcia
and the brewers are on the board for the
first time
yeah the bases are loaded cousins will
face josh bell
he's going to walk him and the nets go
up by three three walks in the inning
did not throw him a fastball on three
and one
so it's a righty righty matchup garcia
breaking ball hit well to center
row blaze back
the nationals win
three in a row
gutsy relieving by cal finnegan machado
a huge double play ball
the inning before
and the nats
win their first game against milwaukee
this year
after the crew swept him here at
nationals park back in late may